ja die absicht der geplanten
ampelkoalition das wahlalter abzusenken
vermutlich ist das aktive wahlalter
gemeint jedenfalls war vom passiven
keine rede von jetzt 18 auf 16 jahren
halte ich für falsch warum weil rechte
und pflichten zusammengehören das kann
man nicht trennen und wenn der staat
sagt also mit 16 jahren handyvertrag
abschließen geht gar nicht dafür fehlt
ja die reife die einsichtsfähigkeit
aber wählen über weitreichende
politische entwicklungen entscheidungen
mit abstimmen könnte es trauen wir den
jungen menschen schon zu das halte ich
für einen widerspruch in sich natürlich
können auch junge menschen mit 16 17
jahren politisch interessiert seien
politisch engagiert seien etwas bewegen
wollen können 14 und 15 jährige aber
auch deshalb meine these die
zivilrechtlichen pflichten war auch die
strafrechtliche verantwortlichkeit die
sollten wir genauso behandeln wie das
wahlrecht auch wenn es daher bei 18
jahren
herr bosbach ich kann ihnen eigentlich
nicht widersprechen über mich wunderts
dass ihr euch cdu politiker so kurz nach
diesem verheerenden wahlergebnis direkt
drauf gehen ich meine wir kennen alle
die zahlen wie sich junge wähler wie
sich erst wähler entschieden haben zu
dem allergrößten teil nicht für die cdu
und anstatt den menschen angebot zu
machen zumindest so zu tun als würde man
darüber nachdenken ob man die jungen
menschen nicht wählen lassen kann direkt
schauen sich die jungen wähler dass man
sagen und nächstes mal mache ich mein
kreuz garantiert wo nicht bei der union
das kann man in doppelter hinsicht
anders sehen erstes unterstellt ja das
alles genauso sehen aber auch viele
jugendliche finden das nicht richtig und
das zweite ist das ist ja der grund
natürlich wissen die genossen und die
grünen und ihr fahrenden die fdp dass
sie überdurchschnittlich gut
abgeschnitten haben wenn das nicht der
fall gewesen wäre wären sie gar nicht
auf die idee gekommen mit der absenkung
um das entscheidende argument ist die
kopplung der vollen geschäftsfähigkeit
mit dem wahlrecht ist völlig unlogisch
zusagen wahlen jahre aktives wahlrecht
jahr
aber auch keine volle geschäftsfähigkeit
sie uns wie sie sagen die jungen leute
wollen gar nicht wählen weil worauf
bezahlen als es gibt ja umfragen über
verschiedene altersgruppen geht und ja
und richtig ist je höher das alter desto
stärker die ablehnung das geht bis 70
und 80 prozent ablehnung aber es ist
nicht so dass alle zwischen 16 und 20
sofort dafür dass nach so dass er sich
jetzt gedacht ja das heißt in der
erfindung der parteien die davon
profitieren ein da haben wir ja schon
lange kommunalwahlrecht ist ja schon ab
18 jahre abgesenkt aber auch eine suche
in szene er werde sich erst auf 616 hat
sich sagen waren sie dafür würde dagegen
dafür da waren sie dafür doch wieso soll
man kommunal sehen der über das ist der
der erlebnisraum in dem ich lebe wo ich
meine entscheidung jeden tag
nachvollziehen kann wo ich auch ganz
anders konfrontiert bin mit den ganz
alltäglichen entscheidungen die in der
kommunalpolitik getroffen werden und bei
dem bei dem wahlrecht so zur
bundestagswahl oder zu den
landtagswahlen da geht es um ganz andere
politische themen und fragestellungen
wer das machen will oder soll dann auch
das geschäftsfeld ich ganz alter auf 16
jahre absenken wenn das das argument ist
die einsichtsfähigkeit ist ausreichend
ausgeprägt so brauche ich beim handy
vertrag mehr einsichtsfähigkeit aus beim
wahlrecht
sprecher hättest du gerne gehabt dass
gerd schröder verkündete hätte so ab 16
jetzt los zum wählen nein weil ich 16
für zu früher halte einfach ich finde
dass ich versuche das argument von herrn
bosbach zu verstehen mit der
geschäftsfähigkeit für mich macht das
gesehen gleichzeitig verstehe ich nicht
wirklich warum man mit 16 kommunal
wählen kann ich verstehe der
persönlichen lebensraum ist erlebbare
aber und damit 18 nicht aber ich hatte
18 für absolut für ausreichend für die
bundestagswahlen weil man da sicherlich
auch ich ja ein festes mindset hat und
sonst kann man auch sagen mit 15 mit 14
warum nicht auch mit 13 wenn es nach
unten keine keine grenze gesetzt
wir müssen natürlich auch wissen dass
diejenigen die älter sind zwischen 15
und 70 fast doppelt so viel sind wie die
die ab 30 nach
von 18 bis 30 sind und
deswegen kann man vielleicht sagen okay
wir holen uns noch ein bisschen was dazu
vielleicht aktivieren wir menschen auch
weil die zum größeren teil eben nicht
wählen gehen aber dass es kein mittel
was funktionieren wird bin ich fest von
überzeugt das geht vielleicht mal eine
wahl so und dann nicht mehr nein ich
finde 18 sollte bleiben wir haben ja
schon differenzierungen auch zum
beispiel strafrecht gilt ja das
jugendstrafrecht weiter auch wenn ich
schon folgen und 15 ja da bin ich
tragfähig richtig aber ich sag jetzt mal
ich bin ja ich kann nach dem
jugendstrafrecht also jetzt ich denke
jetzt gab umgekehrt ich kann nach dem
jugendstrafrecht für strafen auch wenn
ich schon älter bin so das heißt also
diese diese 1800 grenze gilt ja nicht
überall ist ja nicht ja erst mal haben
sie recht aber das gesetz sagt das
gegenteil wer über 18 ist nach dem
erwachsenenstrafrecht und der ausnahme
soll das mildere jugendstrafrecht so die
spruchpraxis
argument 18 16 abgesehen weil ich ja
wieso jetzt richtig keiner mäßig für das
weiter was also ein argument natürlich
vorher was bach könnte ja sein dass wenn
die jugendlichen ab 16 wählen dürfen
dann könnt ihr das pro argument sein
dass auch mehr auf die jugendlichen
geachtet die interessen der jugendlichen
mehr lustig hören und das interesse ist
ja gerade existenziell woche zum 15 tja
irgendwo muss man ja anfangen ja der
bereich volljährigkeit alter ja gut aber
das sehen die jungen menschen nur sehr
anders und sie sagen der erlebnisraum
ist die kommune in der man sich
ausprobieren soll die jungen menschen
würden ganz anders argumentieren die
wollen nämlich gerade zumindest zum
gewissen teil die welt retten und das
beginnt hält nicht damit dass irgendeine
neue straße im dorf gebaut wird sondern
das beginnt damit dass deutschland
früher aus der kohle aussteigt den
verbrenner früher verbietet davon fühlen
die sich existenziell bedroht zumindest
ganz viele und das wollen wir uns gerade
14 15 jährige auch
schulklassen ein zwölfjähriger 13
jährige die damit laufen und das zu
ihrem thema mach das ja alles oft nur
die grüne jugend sagt ja im ersten
schritt will man 2 16 absatz im ersten
schritt aber nur und dann darunter auch
das aber auch recht sagen doch auch
politische forderungen man braucht halt
irgendwelche zahlen die man rein
schreibt man kann ich sagen irgendwas
sondern gesagt halt die sind gerade bei
18 c 216 und dann schauen wir mal weiter
so läuft das nun mal ja gut aber wir
wollen sie angst wie wollen sie ernst
nehmen wir wollen ja nicht sagen die
schreiben sie irgendwelche zahlen rein
sondern wir sagen ja die haben sich was
bei gedacht und sie haben recht bewusst
war wie so 16 wie gekommen wieso nicht
17 ich glaube
aber warum 16 sagen sie mal dass er sich
jetzt warum sony jetzt und die pro
argumente zählen ist immer ein bisschen
schwierig ich bin auch definitiv für das
wahlrecht ab 18 aber ich finde dieses
argument zu sagen die die interessen
würden dann mehr berücksichtigt werden
schon richtig und ich finde konservativ
zum beispiel bedeutet ja auch etwas
anzuschauen aufs exempel zu schauen und
dann vielleicht auch zu verändern nicht
dass alles beim alten bleiben muss und
zum beispiel beim führerschein wurde ja
von 18 auf 17 geändert dass jugendliche
auch schon mit 17 mit den eltern
erfahren konnten ja und dann allein aber
man konnte ihn dann so das scheint auch
schon mit 16 halb machen für 17
lebensjahr für das fand ich zum beispiel
die gute entwicklung haben vielleicht
auch vorher leute gesagt nee also mit 17
sitzen werde aber noch nicht anstellen
man jetzt sagen man und welt mit den
eltern zusammen mit 17 das letztlich zu
haben ich glaube man könnte ja schon
sagen wenn die jugend ist ja auch
politischer geworden also das beweisen
ja auch wirklich studien das heißt
vielleicht einfach mal schauen was man
etwas was meinen sie damit politische
und interessieren sich mehr für politik
als früher gar nicht sein aber jetzt
future der generell um lautet das
interesse größer also die jugend ist
schon politisiert weswegen ich dann
schon sagen würde wir können ja schon
mal gucken ob nicht vielleicht ein oder
zwei jahre vorher ob es nicht auch
einfach verändert hat zu früher die für
sich war gerade das ganze wochenende bei
der jungen union in münster auf dem
deutschlandtag da waren sehr viele
hervorragende junge menschen ich habe
mir jetzt nicht von jedem der
personalausweis zeigen lassen also ich
weiß nicht wie alt die alle waren aber
die tun der union wahnsinnig gut sind
wahnsinnig klar im kopf und aber alle
stramm gegen das war gegen die absenkung
des wahlalters dass er mich dann dann
doch überrascht stehen junge menschen
heizen den parteiposten wirklich ein
prinz darum geht dass das junge menschen
bilden sollen bloß nicht an weiß war das
hauptargument dagegen ich glaube das ist
vor allem das von von herrn bosbach
rechte und pflichten und das muss
zusammen gehen weil demokratie so etwas
heiliges ist man kann nicht das
heiligtum den menschen vertrauen aber
die geschäftsfähigkeit kommt insofern
das ohr an der jugend
[Musik]